here we go again another day
another police officer shooting a
violent criminal
seems like you can't turn on the news
anymore without seeing these sorts of
stories
enough is enough it is long past
time in this country that we had a
national conversation
about the discriminatory practice in
many police departments
to target people who are committing
crimes
that is discrimination we will have that
conversation
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rank discrete they discriminate between
the people committing crimes
and the people not committing crimes
they discriminate between the people
committing crimes and the people who are
having crimes committed against them
that's discrimination my favorite
comment yesterday from timothy brinson
who says when the justice system loses
its integrity the mob can get away with
anything yes absolutely true it's a
simple point
but it's totally true and it's this
point that i think some people
on the more libertarian right they don't
want to
acknowledge sometimes which is that
there will be order order will be
instituted either we can order our own
lives and we can
tamp down our own passions or we can
through our politics
have have a system of justice that will
maintain order
or a bunch of roving street mobs are
going to institute their own sort of
order
but order will be maintained and as the
justice department crumbles and as
liberty is confused for licentiousness
the mobs are ruling that's the way it is
this was not always the case even in the
recent past
we had a far greater semblance of order
if you want to remember
the recent or distant past i would
strongly recommend legacy box
legacy box this is a super simple
mail-in service to have all your video
tapes camcorder tapes film rails and
pictures digitally preserved on a thumb
drive
dvd or at the cloud legacy box is a way
for you to easily
and affordably preserve your past the
process
from start to finish is super duper easy
you pack
and send your media their team digitizes
everything by hand
you enjoy that's it you get back
perfectly preserved digital copies on
thumb drive dvd or the cloud ready to
watch share and enjoy i've mentioned to
you
i had lost some all of my photos
actually of a beloved family member who
had died
i lost them before i really knew about
legacy box and then found a few more
that someone else gave me i mailed them
in i was so happy to have them
i thought this is great but just the
other day in new york
i came across the photos i found them
first thing i'm going to do when i get
them back in my possession
is mail them to legacy box and digitize
them then i will have them forever get
started future proofing your memories
today
so you can gather the family and begin
the trip down memory lane go to
legacybox.com
knowles to get an incredible 40 off your
first order buy today
to take advantage of this exclusive
offer and send it in when you're ready
go to legacybox.com save 40
while supplies last the libs are
defending the stabbing
of children
they are they are doing that to own the
conservatives
or to own the cops or to own the white
people or i don't know they're just
doing it to push their narrative
but they are actually now in the
position of defending
teenage girls stabbing other teenage
girls
just so that a cop won't intervene just
so they can't give the cop credit for
what he did right
you've probably heard about this story
by now if you haven't
a columbus police officer shot
16-year-old
makia bryant this now that the derrick
chauvin trial is over the left needs
some new case to focus on to pretend
that the country is really racist and
terrible
and black people are always being
attacked and white people are the devil
so they're focusing on this case poor
little sixteen-year-old makia bryant cut
down in her prime
by a racist vicious cop except for this
very inconvenient fact that we only know
about because of body camera footage
which was that as when the cop
shot makia bryant she was inches away
from stabbing another girl
we've got the footage cop gets out of
his
car walks up there's some kind of
altercation going on
okay someone gets knocked to the ground
and now a girl there it is girl gets
shot
the girl gets shot and she is
inches away from stabbing with a steak
knife
another young girl it all
it all kind of goes into this melee when
this first person on the side goes down
the cop is turned
facing the person who goes down cop
pulls out his
his gun you got you've got the footage
right there this girl makia bryant
is wielding a giant knife a
pull wraps it around on the side is
about to plunge it down
into this other girl is inches away from
it and then the cop
rightly shoots the attacker
that is the only thing that he could do
while still doing his job in pursuing
justice
a just society would give this cop a
medal
a just society would give this cop an
award
he saved a girl's life and shot a
knife-wielding attacker
our society is going to try to destroy
him he's going to try to put him in
prison is going to try to ruin his
family
he's going to call him a racist because
he shot one black girl to save another
black girl who was about to be stabbed
by the first black girl
but that makes him a racist somehow
that's what's going to happen here some
people want to
they want to say look can't we just all
get along can we just have it both ways
can't look maybe he shouldn't have done
that but you know look i guess the girl
had a knife but you know maybe he should
it's it's just a really sad thing
it's a tragedy we'll get to the tragedy
in a second because we have to get
through some of the
stupid questions surrounding this first
i kid you not
there is the suggestion on the left that
the officer
should have not shot shot the victim or
shot the perpetrator rather
shot to kill he should have just shot
her in the ankle or something
shot her in the wrist shut her shut the
gun right out of her hand
this was a question posed to the police
chief yesterday
one of the big questions that has been
asked primarily on social media and it
may seem like a silly question that like
shouldn't people already know but this
is a legitimate question that a lot of
people are asking
is can an officer
shoot the leg can they shoot somewhere
that would not result in a fatal move
right so a lot of people have said
couldn't he have just shot her in the
leg so she dropped could he have shot
her in the arm something like that
right you know okay we got to pause it
right there before we get to his answer
because he this cop is pretty diplomatic
here and but i will not be diplomatic
this is an extremely dumb question
basically what this reporter is asking
and look i'm not even knocking on the
reporter the reporter is just channeling
what a lot of very
stupid ignorant people on the internet
are saying he's basically
asking hey um couldn't couldn't the cop
have shot the knife out of the girl's
hand
without harming her like clint eastwood
and the good the bad and the ugly
couldn't the cop have had you know when
he heard that harmonica come on
couldn't he have just whipped out his
gun shot the knife out
and then you know the girl she would
have looked really startled like the
like the other guy in the good the bad
and the ugly and then but then they all
kind of would have laughed about it no
one would have gotten hurt couldn't that
come on i saw it
i saw it in the movies that's the quest
no that's not
i won't i won't even explain why you
can't do that i will allow
the expert the cop to explain why that
is not such a great idea
one of the uh the difficult things with
that is um when you're trying
we we don't train to shoot the leg
because that's a small target
we train to shoot center mass what is
available to stop that threat
there was a threat going on a deadly
force threat that was going on so the
officer is trained to
shoot center mass the largest part part
of a body
that is available to them when you try
to start shooting legs
or arms rounds miss and then they
continue on and there are people behind
that
that could be in danger that are not
committing anything
so we try and minimize any danger to
anyone else
if we have to use our firearm when you
pull out a firearm
in real life that is not a video game
when you pull out a f you're not playing
around it's not
here's a warning someone i actually saw
someone say on twitter
why couldn't he fire a warning shot into
the air like he's a mexican gangster
oh you know because i don't know if
you're aware of this
bullets when they go up eventually
because of gravity
they come back down and if you're just
shooting into the air
when they come back down it might not
work out too well for you or for an
innocent bystander why couldn't he just
shot her in the leg one
she's moving like crazy two actually i'm
sorry the first consideration here is
she's got a knife inches from this
girl's body
she's got a knife coming down very
quickly on this girl's body so shooting
her in the leg probably not a smart idea
even if it did work
second leg very very small
area moving very rapidly you've got lots
of people around you don't need bullets
spraying everywhere
when you pull out a weapon and you shoot
that weapon at somebody
you are shooting to kill that person
that's just the way it works
that's what guns do that's what guns are
for
and by the way cops have guns for a
reason cops have guns
to stop bad guys from doing bad things
like this girl who was trying to stab
and by the way when you're stabbing
you're not you're not just playing games
either
when you pull a knife out you stab
somebody you are trying to kill that
person
and this cop saved that girl from
getting killed by that other girl that's
a good thing
that's a good thing or
in our very degraded culture
race-obsessed culture cynical culture
it's an act of racism and i'm not saying
it's just some kook
nut idiot on the internet this is what
is
being pushed without any evidence
actually in the
face of all the evidence by
the white house gensake mouthing off
on a subject about which she knows
nothing to gain political advantage
by smearing people as racists the
killing of sixteen-year-old michaela
bryant by the columbus police is tragic
she was a child we're thinking of her
friends and family in the communities
that are hurting and grieving her loss
we know that police violence just
proportionally impacts
black and latino people in communities
and that black women and girls like
black men and boys
experience higher rates of police
violence we also know that
there are particular vulnerabilities
that children in foster care care
like micaiah face and her death came as
you noted just as america was hopeful of
a step forward after the traumatic and
exhausting trial of derek chovin
and the verdict that was reached so our
focus is
on working to address systemic racism
and implicit implicit bias head-on and
of course to
passing laws and legislation that will
put much needed reforms
into place at police departments around
the country implicit bias
it's uh it's racism it's
what am i basing that on nothing well
probably what the the victim the person
who was about to be stabbed was that a
white person no
okay wasn't a white bro that's too bad
that would have made my argument easier
well whatever it's just it's racism you
know everything's racism it's implicit
too
so if the fact that i can't point to it
proves how you know super duper implicit
and racist it is she was 16 years old
she was she was a child 16 years old the
same democratic party that tells us that
16 year olds are adults and should vote
also tells us 60 they're just children
they don't know anything they can't do
it
the same democratic party that tells us
that a three-year-old can choose to
mutilate himself and castrate himself
and take cross-sex hormones because he
knows
his that he's really a girl even if he's
a boy and the adults can't tell him
nothing because he knows and he's got
the freedom to choose
also tells us that a 16 year old
wielding a knife trying to kill somebody
was you know just a just a child come on
you can't do that
come on man by the way even if
she was just a child if that child
is trying to kill another child and
you've got
less than a second to
intervene either you're going to let the
one child die or you're going to kill
the
child trying to kill the other child
you've still got to do it you've still
got to use that force
that's a tough world that's a real
tragedy split second decisions by the
way
by the way when you want to do things
for yourself i know that in this culture
we're not allowed to do anything for
ourselves and everything has to be
everybody
else's problem when you want to do
something for yourself
like fixing your car i would highly
recommend you go check out rock auto
rockauto.com always has the lowest
prices possible rather than
changing prices based on a bunch of
gimmicks so you know tuesday it's 30
off and then wednesday it goes up 10
again or why would you do that why would
you
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts like for instance
say you happen to need a delphi fg-1456
fuel pump assembly for 2005-2010 honda
odyssey and it costs
i'm just spitballing here 354 dollars at
a big chain store
okay well that's the sort of thing that
you could get at rockauto.com
for 217 bucks wow that's pretty good
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers best of
all prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts go to rockauto.com
the catalog is so easy to navigate
even i can do it great selection you get
all the parts that you need for your car
or truck then you can write
knowles canon wlis in their how did you
hear about us box
so they know that we sent you the
shooting of
micaiah bryant is a tragedy
that is what we are being told
in a sense it is
i'll tell you how it's not and then i'll
tell you how it is the reason it's not a
tragedy
is because it is good when people who
are trying to
stab other people are shot that's a good
thing
because those people who are trying to
stab and
very likely kill other people
are committing a very heinous act and
when they are prevented
from doing that by a bullet that's a
good thing i know that's
a hard saying it's hard to understand
it's hard to
look down this fallen world right as it
is
and say that it is good to kill people
before
they can murder other people as they are
trying to murder
it's hard because we don't want to say
it's not it's awful to shoot anybody
but when we're talking about gradations
here when we're talking about
difficult choices it's better to kill
the criminal
than to let the criminal kill an
innocent person
it is positively good a good decision
to do that now how is it a tragedy
it's a tragedy because this girl
mikaya bryant did a very bad thing
and it's it's sad it's actually sad to
watch people face the consequences
for their bad actions and
become sure this girl had a tough life i
think she was in foster care
she obviously did not have a good family
she obviously was not raised right she
obviously
was not educated she
obviously was not prevented from making
bad evil choices we all have that
inclination we all have that broken
human nature
some of us have better support systems
than others so that that is genuinely
tragic i don't wan
i i know that conservatives in pushing
back on the leftist narrative
here sometimes we go a little too far no
this girl had bad circumstances
and she made evil decisions and it is
actually said even
criminals even even the worst criminals
it is sad tragic to watch them go down
that path
because it doesn't have to happen it's
not inevitable contrary to the left's
fatalist narrative that everyone other
than straight white men
is just a passive figure there only
straight white men according to the left
are fully human
with intellect and will who can are in
control of their lives everyone else
according to that ideology is just to
some passive figure who has moved around
at the whims of straight white men
that's not true that's not true the girl
had
has free will had free will girl had
some intellect the girl could have used
that the right way
she used it the wrong way now as a as a
direct consequence of
her actions she is dead
yep that's that's a sad fact of this
world
and the officer totally did the right
thing and he should be commended for
what he did
and he should be given an award
lebron james disagrees with that the mob
is already coming after
after this police officer the mob being
led by the zillionaire athlete idiot
lebron james
who tweeted out his picture and said all
caps you're next
with a with a an hourglass and it says
accountability accountability is the new
word that the left is using instead of
justice because what the left is calling
for is not justice because justice is an
objective eternal thing
that we perceive and try to
pursue in our lives accountability is
totally a social fact accountability is
just responsiveness responsibility it's
just
it's just what i demand from you well
that then you are accountable to me
but it's not based on anything objective
or eternal
i actually think that's the distinction
at the heart here between accountability
and justice so he's saying yeah we're
coming for you cop
hero cop who did the right thing and
saved a life we're coming for you
lebron james deleted that tweet that's
good
glad he recognized he was wrong but then
he sent out this tweet afterward and he
just talked about you know it's the
being used for bad
things might in the racism but i'm sick
of it it's awful it's terrible nobody
no no you don't get it you don't get it
lebron
you don't get that it was absolutely
right and
just for that cop to shoot mikaya bryant
i don't think he could have behaved any
more appropriately
because he it's not like he she runs out
of the house and he just starts shooting
he waited until the knife was inches
from the other girl
and then he shot her that's a good you
should lebron james not when you
apologize when you take that tweet down
not only should you apologize for that
tweet you should thank that cop for
doing his job
and for pursuing justice and you should
say i lebron james
a total dummy was wrong
i i leapt to a conclusion that was not
right
thank you sir for pursuing justice you
think that's going to happen i don't
think so
because lebron is a victim don't you
know
lebron james can't leave his house
without being hunted down by
racist white people is that so
lebron he's he is this poor aggrieved
man
who lives in a world of white privilege
i do not want to be lectured by lebron
james
on privilege i you almost can't blame
lebron here
for the same reason that you feel bad
for criminals
you also feel bad for totally benighted
ignorant idiots like lebron james
because
i think he genuinely believes this stuff
flies in the face of objective reality
flies in the face of everything we see i
think lebron james really does believe
that he's a victim that he has
legitimate grievance
that this country a black man can't make
it in this country
lebron he thinks this from his i i
imagine
golden palace that he's from his throne
that he's sitting on in a zillion dollar
house
one of the most beloved for whatever
reason and
wealthy and famous people in the country
can't make it though because of the
color of his skin right
he believe and the i'm not i'm not being
facetious when i say i sort of feel bad
for his deep ignorance
he has been raised in a culture
that increasingly teaches people this
sort of thing
lebron's a little too old to have been
totally educated this way
but younger people are educated this way
this is what they are told this is
what you're taught by critical race
theory for instance
which is very much in the news these
days critical race theory is a
derivation of critical theory which is
part of this
radical cultural upheaval that began a
hundred years ago
or more and that has flowered into
political correctness and woke-ism and
cancel culture
i explain this history at length in my
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now for
pre-order
you can get it right now critic the
critical race theory part
it's just part and parcel of it but what
it tells you is
you can't make this a hopelessly racist
bigoted terrible country and you can't
make it so you got to hate the system
and tear it down
what are we going to do about that well
oklahoma state senators
are finally figuring it out much more so
i mean
they're really leading on this issue
compared to
so many of the squishes around the
country in in the republican party
oklahoma state senators have introduced
a bill to ban critical race theory from
public schools and universities
this would prohibit teachers and
administrators
and other staff from teaching that one
race or sex is inherently superior to
another not allowed to do that anymore
that an individual by virtue of his race
or sex is inherently racist sexist or
oppressive whether consciously or
unconsciously
that is being taught as gospel truth in
board rooms and universities and schools
right now
that will be banned an individual should
be discriminated against or receive
adverse treatment solely or partly
because of his or her race or sex yep
that's being taught
members of one race or sex cannot and
should not attempt to treat others
without respect
to race or sex that is being taught an
individual's
moral character is necessarily
determined by his or her race or sex
that is being taught
and all this stuff would be banned this
has to be banned
i've said before there are three
positions on this
poison in the classroom there's the
position where you support it you say
yeah we want all this
leftist stuff that's great let's go
along with it this is terrific
then there's the position of well it
shouldn't be mandatory but it can be
taught if the schools want it to be
taught
and then there's the conservative
position no
academic freedom is a hoax to use the
term of william f buckley jr
this is a farce just a trick of
political
correctness that the left is used to
destroy our culture education is
necessarily
limited exclusive coercive
cert we're going to teach some things
we're not going to teach other things
we're going to
bring some things into the classroom
we're going to ban other things from the
classroom
and one of the things we're going to ban
is this poison this trash
critical race theory not going to allow
it in and you know what teachers if you
do teach this
you'll be punished maybe you'll be fired
for it
but michael what about freedom yeah what
about freedom
this undermines freedom this thing there
is a thought that stops thought and that
is a thought that ought to be stopped
the the position of critical race theory
is that objective reality is an illusion
our faculties of reason are fake and the
country is
evil and not deeply unjust in all its
institutions including the
educational ones if you allow that idea
to fester you
undermine the whole thing you undermine
our conception of liberty you undermine
the whole country
gotta get rid of it gotta kick it out
gotta get a lot
tougher then we'll be talking about mr
lebron james today
his cop hating america go check out his
show later on and then get ready
for candace's show got a great candace
owens show
coming up on friday if you're not
already a member you're missing out on
candace
the newest talk show here by candace
owens
this week's episode is a major truth
bomb as candace dives right into the
derek joven trial verdict
and gives her breakdown on george
floyd's death it's certain to be very
politically correct you do not want to
miss this week's special guest also dana
white president of the ultimate fighting
championship
which is the largest mma organization in
the world show streams on fridays at 9
pm eastern apm central only
only at dailywire.com you can also get
25
off a new membership with code candace
head on over to daily wire
we'll be right back with a lot more
we're going to need tough serious people
in our politics to bring our country
back from the brink
and we may be getting one not the hero
we deserve
but the hero we need that would be mark
mccloskey you'll remember
mark mccloskey and his wife holding
those
he had the the it looked like an ar-15
she had that little james bond gun
and when blm started storming up and
breaking their property
they did not roll over they did not lie
down they did not say please take
whatever you want because of your claims
of historical grievance and no they
pulled out their guns and pointed that
at them and said get off my property
get off my lawn i should get off my lawn
now
so they also did this while wearing
their like great brooks brothers
you know pink polo shirt white chinos
or you know khaki colored chinos anyway
i was hoping that either the mccloskeys
would become magazine cover models for
the cover of the new j
press catalog or that they would get
involved in politics
looks like it's going to be the latter
by the way i spoke to mark mccloskey
right when all this happened because
there was a rumor that he's a democrat
or something and supported blm
he said that's just not true he does not
do that he gave like 50 bucks once to
his
democrat buddy who was running for dog
catcher or something but he's a lifelong
conservative republican
so he is considering running for u.s
senate in missouri
my hot take on this i don't really know
very much about mark mccloskey i don't
know anything really about the other
candidates for senate
but my my first gut really
analytical reaction is awesome
great super cool great love that love
i'm really glad he's running for senate
i don't i don't know about his political
philosophy
i don't know his his
intricate ideas about entitlement reform
or something like that
i don't i don't know about his personal
history
here's what i do know that guy stood up
to blm when it counted
when when it was getting real when it
was on the line when a
violent angry mob came to destroy his
property and threaten him
and his wife he stood up to them
and he faced legal threats because of
that didn't care faced physical threats
obviously because of that
didn't care he stood up to defend
not just his property not just his life
but to defend what is right to stand up
for justice
that gives him i think a real real
advantage in the race
all the jokes about how great they
looked you know and the polos and the
guns and everything
that actual those images did represent
something they weren't just
memes they actually represented a
stance for justice very few people
are willing to do that in washington
gives him gives him a very good
advantage
speaking of some people who actually do
stand up for tough things in washington
they're few and far between senator ted
cruz
my co-host on verdict senator cruz
absolutely nailed this
issue of election fraud and the double
standards
and this massive left-wing power grab he
had stacey abrams the fake governor of
georgia
who refused to admit that she lost the
governor race pretended that she won the
race
never faced any adverse consequences
from that even though now we're told if
you ever question an election you're
going to be de-platformed and ostracized
and censored
if you're a republican if you're a
democrat you have to question the
elections that you lose
ted cruz had stacey abrams right in
front of her he said hey just once and
for all
do you admit you lost the election
ms abrams it's been over two years
and you still refuse to concede that you
lost the race for governor in georgia in
2018.
you have said that quote you do not
concede that the process was proper
and that quote they stole it from the
voters of georgia
yes or no today do you still maintain
that the 2018 georgia election was
stolen
as i have always said i acknowledged at
the very beginning
that i that brian kemp won
under the rules that were in place what
i object to
are rules that permitted thousands of
georgia voters to be denied their
participation in this election
to have their votes cast out
i'm going to ask you to please answer
the question i asked which is do you
yes or no do you still maintain the 2018
election was stolen
that's your language my
full language was that it was stolen
from the voters of georgia
okay so there's the answer who else
would it be stolen from
who would an election be stolen from
when you cheat in an election you were
ultimately stealing the vote
of of the voters so she's saying yes i
maintain that
i maintain that the 2018 election i
maintain this without any evidence
that the 2018 election was stolen from
me
and that brian kemp is illegitimate
therefore right i think that's the
that's the implication
if you were to say that same thing about
the 2020 presidential election
you would be kicked off of the internet
and you might be investigated by the fbi
you might be called an insurrectionist
and un-american
but if you say that about the 2018
georgia governor's election
which which had far far fewer
irregularities
far less evidence in georgia 2018 that
anything weird was going on
if you said that about georgia you'd be
celebrated you'd be
you'd be stacey abrams yourself so she
makes this argument you know
it's really it was racism
and it black votes were suppressed
so senator cruz because senator cruz
people forget he's a very good
prosecutor he's argued cases before the
supreme court
that was his old job before he got into
the senate
he comes with the receipts and he just
shreds her stupid argument do you know
in georgia whether the percentage of of
african-american georgians who are
registered to vote and who turned out to
vote is it higher or lower than the
national average
it is higher than the national average
because georgia is one of the largest
states with an african-american
population but if that's not
tied to the size of the population the
percentage of black georgians who are
registered to vote in 2018
is 64.7 percent that compares to 60.2
percent as the national average the
percentage of georgians who voted in
2018 the election you claim was stolen
from you
was 56.3 that's higher than the national
average of 48
let me ask you this ms abrams in 2018 do
you know which demographic group in
georgia
had the highest registration percentage
and the highest turnout percentage
i have a guess that i will defer to you
for the answer
the answer is african-americans had the
highest registration and the highest
turnout despite your claiming
that the election was stolen and there
was somehow voter suppression
i can't tell if stacey abrams is dull or
dishonest this may be not
maybe isn't an either or sort of
situation
because cruz says hey do you know
you know what state did very very well
was like a real leader
in in terms of the percentage of black
voters who actually registered turned
out to vote
and she said well yes georgia that's
true yeah we were good at that with the
black voters but only because georgia
has a really big black population
you see the problem there the percent
the percentage of black voters in
georgia
that are registered or voting has
nothing to do with the size of the
population it's a percentage
it's it's okay whatever the population
is this is the proportion of them
that were registered and went out to
vote
and so cruz points that out he says well
are you serious right now are you
kidding me
no let me explain to you what a
percentage is stacey abrams
and then she wises up then he goes on
and he says hey do you know this do you
know that do you know this and
eventually she says i
defer to your expertise as well she
should
as well she should it took how long did
it took one minute
to shred the whole argument over the
voter suppression of the black people in
georgia in 2018
took less than one minute for ted cruz
he's a sharp guy maybe it would take two
minutes for other people
but you could do it just look at the
numbers
meanwhile when you talk about
irregularities in 2020
you had in the case of pennsylvania
election officials
explicitly obviously violating the state
constitution when it comes to the use of
widespread mail-in ballots
but no we're not allowed to talk about
that
the issue here is that it doesn't really
come down to an argument
stacey abrams realized she's she's at
least sharp enough to realize oh
gosh i'm about to get wrecked by ted
cruz okay i'll pull up i'll try to push
back a little
then i will humiliate myself by
appearing not to understand what a
percentage is
and then i will i'll just lay back and
let cruz do it
because ultimately it doesn't really
matter
it doesn't matter how persuasive that
argument
is doesn't matter how thoroughly stacey
abrams point is debunked
i think what the left is interested in
right now is not
logical argument and persuading or being
persuaded i think they are interested in
the use of power attaining political
power
wielding that political power and
pushing one's will absent
one's intellect or the rigor of one's
logic
that's what this is really about so you
got problems in the
legislature problems in the executive
and then into judiciary i want to turn
to la
la right now is ordering the city
to offer homeless people
housing by the fall there's a lot of
homeless people a lot of bums and
derelicts on the streets of los angeles
especially skid row it's like a third
world country
and it's amazing too because you'll be
in downtown l.a and you'll be in some
areas that are kind of nice
they're actually pretty impressive lots
of money there then you make a wrong
turn and you are in you're
surrounded by hundreds and hundreds of
bums and drug addicts and criminals and
lunatics and derelicts and you think
how on earth is this taking place one in
the united states and two in what is
considered to be a major city
in the united states so the judge u.s
district
judge david carter has uh outlined the
problems of homelessness here and he
says it's all about racism
now his his premise here is wrong but
his his policy conclusion i think
actually might have some point he says
quote
through redlining containment eminent
domain exclusionary zoning and
gentrification
designed to segregate and disenfranchise
communities of color
the city and county of los angeles
created a legacy of entrenched
structural racism
as shown most clearly in the present
crisis of homelessness
the effects of structural racism
continue to threaten the lives of people
of color in los angeles
very offensive thing he's saying he's
saying yeah if you're black
you're just going to live on the streets
on skid row because you're black and you
can't do anything
and no white people live on the streets
of skid row and no black people have
mansions
no black people have even homes black
people can't make it
like lebron james he's living on skid
row right because of structural racism
you know a real irony here too is do you
know who famously spent several days
getting into violent altercations over
crack cocaine
sales on skid route you know who did
that hunter biden very famously
during one of his more than week-long
benders
in los angeles winds up on skid row
getting into fist fights and haggling
over the price of crack
hunter biden last i checked not
a person of color not i don't think so i
don't know
corn pop maybe but joe bi or
hunter biden rather i don't think so
i don't it's not a racial thing i don't
think that structural racism forced
these force the drug addicts to take all
the drugs
forced the lunatics to live on the
street force the criminals
to commit crime i don't think structural
racism caused any of that i think
the brokenness of man and then
the evil choices that man makes and then
the
the erosion of one's own discipline and
free will because of those evil choices
and because of
the habit of vice i think that's what
caused it
but i will say i do think
that the city of los angeles should
house these people
i do i actually do it is a dysfunctional
act for people to live on the street
it should not be tolerated and
what la wants to pretend what a lot of
liberals want to pretend is that
we got rid of the insane asylums in the
60s and 70s because we didn't
it was wrong it was taking away people's
freedom to put these lunatics and insane
asylums
they're so much more free now that
they're living in squalor on the street
no they're not
the reason they're not free is because
they're not in command of their
intellect and their will
so now so they're living in filth on the
street and in danger
of physical violence all the time that's
not better than living an insane asylum
there were two types of housing that
the city of los angeles should provide
to these bums on skid row
insane asylums which should be rebuilt
it would be an act of compassion
to rebuild the insane asylums and take
people living in filth on the street and
put them into places that are
probably not going to be very nice but
it's going to be better than living on
the street
and this is this is a difficult fallen
world and if we can make a little
improvement here we should they should
either put them in insane asylums
or prisons it's a dysfunctional act to
live on the street
a lot of these people they're drug
addicts okay
that should be again that should be
against the law where it's not it is
against the law in very many places
we should not have people strung out on
meth and pcp and crack like hunter biden
running around the streets
threatening the public order put them in
jail
it's a good place for them and then who
else
just loafers and the indigent probably
got to arrest them too
because you're not you don't have a
claim you're not allowed to live on the
sidewalk
it's not good for you it's not good for
society
it's not civilized yes i sort of agree
with this judge
for all sorts of different reasons i
agree with this judge how's the homeless
put them in jails or institutions
absolutely
the political order is changing rapidly
you are seeing a realignment you are
seeing
some people who were liberals and
moderates
who would would have called themselves
democrats or on the left they are
they're watching the left right now
undermine
our system of government call for the
abolition of cops
march through the streets burning down
private businesses and houses and
government buildings and they're looking
at they're saying
i can't can't do that i'm out they're
seeing the left
push transgender ideology on kids
castrate little children and they're
saying i'm out
they're seeing the left defending a girl
who was trying to stab another girl
just to own the cops or whatever and
they're saying i'm not part of this
you've seen that you saw a lot of people
move over to the trump camp who were
previously not engaged in politics or
who are not republicans
you're also seeing former republicans
who were liberal squishes leave the
party
you said i'm referring of course to most
famously i guess bill crystal
who was a major major republican figure
who then left the republican party and
now supports democrats
and works in democrat activism because
he doesn't like the new direction of the
republican party
you had the the remaining never trump
contingent
very there aren't very many of the never
trumpers that were left in 2020
but people like david french for
instance or i think jonah
jonah goldberg is still never trump who
they don't like
i'm not even personally attacking them
i'm just saying they don't like where
the republican party is going so they're
leaving and they will either
totally check out or in some cases will
actively support democrats
will actively vote for joe biden
and then there's george w bush who was
our last republican president before
donald trump
and george w bush was i think a little
upset at the way trump treated his
brother jeb
and i suspect he did not vote for donald
trump
he did not attend the rnc and
now he's coming out and really markedly
criticizing the gop
he went on nbc news where his daughter
works and he was pushing his new book
which is an art collection i actually
have one of president bush's art art
collections
it's like a coffee table book of
veterans it's
pretty impressive for a uh for an
amateur a relatively recent painter so
he's got a new one about immigrants
he was plugging the book and he took the
opportunity to
attack the gop if you were to describe
the republican party as you see it today
yeah how would you describe it uh i
would describe it as
isolationist protectionist and to a
certain extent nativist
are you disappointed well it's not
exactly my vision
yeah but you know what i'm just an old
guy they put out the pasture so
just a simple painter the simple painter
so even if you don't like what george
bush is saying here and i obviously
have great disagreements you do remember
how likable this guy is you do and i
think it's sort of genuine
i actually have i really do have a soft
spot for george w bush even though i
don't like
the direction that he took the
republican party i'm very glad that his
brand of conservatism is over
one can one can have an honest
disagreement here and just say
yeah hey you might be a nice guy but
your vision of the party
that's that's over that's the past it's
good that that's over we're moving in a
stronger more conservative
direction is the gop isolationist now i
don't believe that
i think we're more skeptical of
wilsonian adventurism and creating
madisonian democracies in the middle
east
but i don't i think it's unfair to call
that isolationist
is it protectionist well i think we're a
little
we're a little skeptical of total free
trade where all of our trading partners
cheat and they violate wto treaties
and they get an advantage and they
illegally subsidize they're stealing
aluminum to
use the and they illegally uh inflate
their currency
in china and we have to play by a
different set of rules i don't that
doesn't even seem very free to me
so yeah we're skeptical of that nativist
what does that word even mean
we think that the government of the
united states should
protect the citizens of the united
states more than foreigners yeah
duh that's what every country should do
it's not a racial thing
there are a lot of native americans i'm
a native american lebron james is a
native american
a lot of people born in this country
all different sorts of races and
backgrounds but
we take in millions and millions of
people every year more than any other
country in the world by a country mile
and we have something like i think 51
million immigrants or something living
in the country right now
it's a lot and if you're not going to
assimilate people that that really does
threaten
the integrity of your culture in your
country not saying it's because we hate
the mexicans or something it's just you
can't
if you have a totally open border you
don't have a country anymore is that
nativist no come on give me a break and
now president bush very
very upset and worried about afghanistan
because
joe biden has an ad trump started it and
now biden is concluding it
saying we're going to pull out of
afghanistan george bush doesn't like
that very much
my first reaction was wow these girls
are going to have real trouble with the
taliban
and a lot of gains have been made and uh
and so i'm deeply concerned
about the plight of women and girls in
in in that country i think we should
have held off on that decision well i
think we'll see i mean the time will
tell i i
i think the administration hopes that
the girls are going to be okay through
diplomacy
uh we'll find out all i know is the
taliban when they
had the run of the place they were
brutal yeah brutal
yeah um do you can you believe it's been
20 years since we went in there
uh you know uh we went into korea in 52.
yeah we went into germany yeah 42
yeah 44. yeah so yeah no
i mean yeah 20 years i guess you're to
say can you believe
you've been out office you were in there
first 20 years ago
yeah time flies time flies and so
all i wish george bush has an honest
position here which is that we should
stay in
afghanistan forever i guess but because
there's
at a certain point you leave and then
guess who's coming back
these tribal warriors and the taliban so
the girls are going to be in just as bad
a position whether we leave today or we
leave in 100 years
you're not going to root that out you're
not going to totally transform
afghanistan which is a very ancient
place
into some into fifth avenue or something
but i just wish he were honest about it
and say look my my vision
is an american global empire and
i support that on the basis of a sort of
abstract liberalism
and following in the footsteps of
woodrow wilson say
and so yeah we're never going to leave
and we're going to invade more countries
and we're going to make them
more like us and that's the way it's
going to be
but that argument wouldn't work it
obviously isn't going to work and i
don't even think they'd admit it let's
not forget the bushes have never been
particularly conservative
george jeb called illegal immigration
act of love george w called himself a
compassionate conservative
as opposed to what the heartless
conservatives george h.w bush said he
wanted a kindler gentler nation
nancy reagan famously asked kindler and
gentler then whom meaning
reagan you know the more conservative
guy and prescott bush
helped to found planned parenthood okay
so it's not
i have a piece on this at the daily wire
too so it's not not even an attack on
the bushes just saying
they represent the liberal wing of the
republican party now we're moving
back to a more conservative part of the
republican party bushes have represented
the liberal wing of that party since
1952 at least
and now we're moving in a more
conservative direction that's
a good thing and it's gonna you're gonna
hear a lot of
heart strings and a lot of narratives
and a lot of
of unpersuasive arguments we ought to
keep our eyes
on justice i'm michael nolsas the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show the media lie about
systemic police racism the white house
the media and lebron james target a
police officer for shooting a black
teenager who was trying to stab
another black teenager and the bite
administration cracks down on police
department so everything is going great
that's today on the bench hero show give
it a listen